Meet BTS, a seven-member South Korean boy band from Seoul.
The band has sold millions of albums and is one of the most watched artists on YouTube,...
...not to mention their stadium shows around the globe have quickly sold out.
It's estimated that BTS is worth about 3.6 billion dollars per year to the economy of South Korea...
...and more than 1 billion dollars in consumer exports.
The idols as South Koreans call its megastars...
...were the reason that 1 in 13 foreign tourists visited the country in 2017.
BTS even partnered with Visit Seoul on a tourism campaign.
Namsan Tower and Banpo Bridge, which were featured in videos for the campaign,...
...have become hotspots for tourists.
Should BTS maintain their popularity,  they could generate 37 billion dollars...
...in economic value for South Korea over the next 10 years.